normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government the
vake ramas Swami I love this one defends
debunked conspiracy theories he shared
at Republican debate he elevated false
or groundless claims about January 6 us
demographic changes here's the crazy
thing this is what really really bothers
me these guys who work for ABC News I
assume they're either uh really really
stupid or intentionally lying January 6
definitively
without question provably and
adjudicated as such is an inside job
next question and and and and I'll
clarify now because I know I tried to
hammer that one really really hard
several individuals had already have
have been acquitted because the judge
outright said police welcomed them in
there's video of police opening the
doors and letting people in the response
we've gotten is oh well you got to
understand why they did it okay explain
to me why the Q was given a guided tour
they walk to a door try to open it it
doesn't open then they bring him they
bring the guy to the CATE Chambers the
argument is they were overwhelmed they
had no choice they just gave in like the
cop who took a selfie there's more than
one cop who took selfies with people
opened these doors there are doors that
have are are mag sealed you know this
better than I do that they're mag locked
you can't just open them someone has to
De deactivate the electric current to
open the door somebody did this
Alexandri okazi Cortez was actually one
of the first I me probably not one of
the first but of Democrats she actually
said and this is like a year and a half
ago there were police officers who are
Fanning people in moving barricades
opening doors and she wants answers I'm
like I completely agree the those are
those are facts so I'll say it this way
the media is claiming ramas Swami
statements was were debunked the said it
now looks like it may have been ins an
inside job here's the game they're
playing they're conflating inside job
with Joe Biden was involved or Nancy
Pelosi was involved here's here's how
here's how I I'll put it for you a
thousand people work at a bank one day
the bank gets robbed two guys who worked
there opened the doors for the robbers
who then made off that's called an
inside job the the degree to which the
guys were involved who knows they may
have gotten a phone call and they said
hey look we're going to slip you $100
bill just open the door for us and
they're like sure I guess I don't even
know what's going on still an inside job
Inside Job refers to someone on the
inside facilitated what happened so
while you have people fighting with cops
on one side you have cops opening other
doors and letting people in he also and
uh well he also talked about great
replacement and this is what really got
people all riled up is that he basically
said it was policy for Democrats so uh
instead of getting ahead of myself I
want to we we we'll stick it to the
we'll stick to the January 6 first and
then we'll get into the other other
portion the V said why am I the only
person on the stage at least who can say
that January 6 now does look like it was
an inside job they say that baseless
idea has become popular among fringes on
the far right and social on social media
at times even winning support from
lawmakers including Senator Mike Lee who
last month claimed without evidence that
there were undercover federal agents
disguised in the crowd during the riding
at the US capital as Congress had
gathered to certify Trump's election
defeat well I'm curious your thoughts uh
on all this I don't know if there were
federal agents i' I've heard that
claimed I don't know if you know
anything about it yeah I I do believe
there were federal agents as well
um and I believe we had Christopher Ray
and a Homeland Security uh Committee
hearing I think two two weeks ago and
when asked that question he basically
gave the tagline you know I'm not going
to comment on any you know um any
operation any investig ongoing
investigation type type deal I I
actually asked one of the questions I
asked him uh was hey why hasn't the pipe
bomber been caught right I found that
fascinating that and the way kind of the
way I posed the question to him was so
how many how many people did you guys
arrest at January 6 and it was I don't
know hundreds and hundreds of people
right the one the one guy that could
have you know basically created multiple
mass casualty events with his pipe bombs
meaning killed or injured you know you
know dozens and dozens of people um you
know just they the FBI can't find that
guy and I just it just it's wild to be
because DC is one of DC is one of the
most heavily fortified
defended um and recorded cities you know
um in the entire country and so you're
telling me that you know and maybe this
maybe this is you know too
conspiratorial for some but it just
strikes me as odd that the this guy he
couldn't um he was so proficient that
he's able to avoid the most proficient
law enforcement organization in the
world yet he couldn't get his his pipe
bombs to go off right and or people are
arguing oh well they got them before you
know they got the pipe bombs before they
were you know set to go off I just I'm
sorry man I don't buy that this guy has
been avoiding you know the FBI I also
when I look at guys like Ray EPS the
fact that Ray EPS was in the crowd he
was M seen multiple times he's caught on
camera multiple times telling people we
got to go into the building we got we
got to go into the capital and years
into this he's not arrested even though
you know guys on like revolver news you
know the guys at revolver continually
reporting on this stuff it just stinks
to high heaven and then you got that
right on the back end of the you know
Michigan deal with gritchen Gretchen
Whitmer I I I think the FBI has you know
needs to be reeled in and it's why many
of us tried to deny them the ability to
uh get their new FBI headquarters
probably about a month and a half ago
and once again the uni party moved in
lock step to give them their new I think
it was like $300 million building in DC
no it's not going to be in DC I can't
remember where it is it it is uh it's
amazing to me that they're able to um
track down a garage pull rope remember
that one yeah the uh who who who was
that guy there b Bubba Wallace or Bubba
yeah yeah it was a garage P I can't
remember his name said a dozen agents so
last year we were uh swatted we had uh
we we had um I don't like using the
phrase swatted because people don't
understand what that means let's just
say uh swatting like events 15 times and
I'll clarify a couple of them were fake
bomb uh bombings and so uh this ranges
from I think it was a it was like
actually it was like four or five two of
them were physical devices I shouldn't
say devices were physical objects that
were sent here and i' I've only somewhat
disclosed this before and so the they
sent a robot out they got this uh they
have this device device it's like I
don't know if it's an x-ray or whatever
but they uh try and blast the box to see
what's inside of it and whoever whoever
did this knew the capabilities of law
enforcement and obstructed the view of
the device that seeks to look inside the
Box externally right they put a panel
behind it like a reflective panel and
they blast it with like x-rays or
something and they said we can't get in
so we're bringing the robots in we also
had to we were forced to evacuate the
building for 3 hours and the stream went
live to like ,000 people for 3 hours of
the Deb nothing in the room they never
they never caught these guys we've been
we've had uh police sent here on
numerous fake calls some were actual
humans a human voice some were uh uh
robotic and they never catch these guys
but pull rope and even even after we
submitted a bunch of evidence and told
them like guys like this information may
like we've we've got evidence they just
said we don't care at all well if you
were at a if you were a concerned parent
at a school board meeting to them I bet
your issue would be I bet they your
issue would be resolved man you mean if
you were a liberal parent concerned
about conservatives complaining yeah
your your your issue would be resolved y
this pipe bomb thing at the capital is
is always kind of fascinating me in that
it hasn't been talked about that much
like I heard about it was there actual
did they produce the pipe bombs was
there evidence that did they show them
and be like these are what we found and
then like show evidence that it was they
were legitimately found was there any
evidence of like recording finding them
or any of that yeah there there's
there's video footage of them you know I
think retrieving the pipe bombs but cuz
it it adds it heightens the the danger
of the day knowing that there were bombs
placed so that of course it wouldn't I
mean it doesn't it wouldn't surprise me
if people came out later like yeah you
know we did that to intensify the the
fear so that we could shut it down
quicker like I think a lot of this is
like let's just get it put I mean it if
you told me they had no FBI agents in in
the crowd that day I'd be kind of kind
of disappointed with the FBI you're
going to do a riot on the capital and
you don't have FBI agents out there like
looking at stuff you get your get your
agents on the field let's let's let's
address that like let's just say they
were caught off guard and there's a
bunch of there's there's 250,000 Trump
supporters marching around the feds had
no one no no that that's that's that's
an absurdity I'm sorry they knew well in
advance yo I'm some dude who just
complains on the internet and I read a
Fox news story that Trump was calling
for protest I was like wow that's going
to be crazy yeah Med matters ran a
hitpiece on me claiming that I had four
knowledge because I said something in
November where I was like yo these proud
boys and 3centers or whatever are going
to like stor are rush to DC and like
storm the White House or something like
they're not going to accept a trump
defeat literally didn't happen didn't
happen in November it was January way
later I had no idea it was speculation
based on news reports if I can speculate
that you mean the FBI didn't actually
have any plan for security or undercover
uh agents to be there that's the one I'm
thinking about ra apps cuz when that
when that was the one thing when I first
was like like a lightning bolt like what
the when he was screaming for people to
go to the build go in the building and
then he didn't get arrested I was like
what in the hell like at least arrest
him and do like a dog and pony show to
make it look like he was one of the bad
guys can can I just point this out isn't
it crazy that we this is a story from
the New York Post isn't it crazy that it
was March of 2023 two years more than
two years later we got the footage
showing Capital Cap Capital cops
escorting the Q and on Shaman to the
senate floor how was that not disclosed
immediately especially considering they
they're locking they they locked this
guy up or they at the time they were
about to lock him up you see this video
where they're actually walking him to
the doors and opening the doors for him
yeah I'm sorry that's an inside job yeah
and it's like maybe they didn't want a
prolong Siege of the building they
didn't want all the windows to get
broken out so like just get it over with
get in here but that they're aring for
trespassing like dude there's a video
where a cop walks in he's like can you
guys please leave and I think it's the
shaman he's like well take care of it
will'll be nice yo they let him in in
the first place if he was if he was
being that nice they didn't even need to
open the door for him they could have
been like buddy no you got to go and he
would have been like okay the dude's
bumbling around and they're guiding him
to these places I just did a show with
with Michael mice and Jacob Chanley the
guy we're talking about so he's out of
jail I don't know what his what happened
did he serve the full sentence I was
trying to look up I asked him if it was
what solitary was like it was hor on
Earth thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IR L podcast hang out with
us live Monday through Friday at 8:00
p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net